are you telling me now you're not going
to eat it yes it depends unless it looks
really good it has to look so good I
want to shave my head to eat it cuz I
have to bro I pissed squ Ramy
[Music]
off welcome to scrambled where I'm
cooking my favorite dish scrambled eggs
with some close friends and today we
have one of the biggest YouTubers on the
planet an entrepreneur phist and I just
found out this guy is crazy please
welcome Mr Beast thank you what a great
hype man I love it yeah that's good
first of all what a competition Charlie
talking Factory where did the idea start
from well um okay so wow he just gets
right into it I love how he's so good he
doesn't even need to focus on he's doing
it so we uh just got done finished
filming uh my video where I gave away a
chocolate factory and uh uh you might
not believe this but it came from the
movie really WKA well we grew up with
that right ex and it was that sort of
Magical Mystery Tour was full of
chocolate but to that where were you
when you thought I'm going to do the
whole thing oh yeah honestly someone
tweeted it at me and I saw the tweet I
was like like they were like yo you
should recreate uh the chocolate River
from Willy wer Chocolate Factory and
then we were talking about it and we're
like well if we're going to make the
chocolate River might as well just make
the Chocolate Factory and then oh my
gosh those buns look so delectable love
that toast that buns now you got the
most amazing line of burgers right okay
and we have our own Burger stores but
have you ever had the perfect breakfast
sandwich in a burger uh no is that what
you're making for me that's exactly what
we're going to make so scrambled egg
smoked salmon and some that
wait do you want me to take a bite of it
do you know what that is uh white
truffles right uh that is a black
truffle from perago that's right oh that
would explain why it's black amazing
Absolut amazing amazing I want to take a
bite so bad so I have to also say that
I'm doing a video where I try not to eat
food for 30 days and if I do have to
shave my head um which is why this is an
interesting opportunity because I'm
going to try not to eat what he makes
but if it looks good enough I might cave
is what I told him so I'm going to make
a sandwich and you telling me now you're
not going to eat it yes it depends
unless it looks really good it has to
look so good I want to shave my head to
eat it cuz I have to bro I pissed squ
ram off you know that's probably like
the fourth time he's gotten mad at me
but I honestly I enjoy it try a little
slice just just take a little bite right
um how do you fast for 30 days how far
are you need uh yeah so today's day 14
um basically well I'm not a doctor so I
don't want to tell you how so was last
time you had a poo uh oh go he asked me
that earlier then he was like actually
I'm going to wait till we're doing this
uh he wanted you guys to know so I
haven't ate food in 14 days and when I
stopped eating I pooped on day number
two and then I didn't poop again for a
week and I was like oh I guess no more
poop since I'm not eating and then
randomly on day 10 I'm not eating food I
had another bowel movement I called the
doctor I was like I swear I didn't eat
blah he's like oh yeah that's normal
when your body breaks down your fat it
creates waste blah blah blah so why why
are you doing it what's the what's the
objective uh well uh oh gosh I think a
for me I have Crohn so uh not eating
will help lower the inflammation in my
gut B I also like just pushing myself
that's why I buried myself alive walked
to Marathon the world's longest pairs of
shoes and stuff so I just like you know
I'm just kind of training my mental
toughness and this is this is pushes me
to the max oh my gosh that looks would
you make it 30 days uh we'll see depends
I'm I'd say there's a high probability I
cave now I'm so hungry bro comment how
long you've ever fasted before just so
look do you see can you tell my eyes
were getting a little water just looking
at this food is making me tear up a
little bit so Chef's graay all day long
we don't sit down and eat dinner before
cook dinner in a kitchen you gray so
it's small bites I mean yeah we eat four
or five times a day but small tiny bowls
because you know you just can't sit down
and have that big lunch that big dinner
and then think where's the energy to
taste for that level of perfection yeah
in terms of when you're absolutely
nailing dishes and season them to
Perfection so we never season these
scrumbled eggs until they halfway Cooks
turns them gray turns them watery and
they'll go so sort of sort of almost
like a a dark slurry color wow so I've
just got my eggs touch a butter in there
and we go on for one minute scrape down
as we clean okay and as we stir just
constantly scrape down and that way what
age did you start cooking so Mom was a
chef in strapon aen this little sort of
greasy spoon Cafe and she sort of had
three jobs so I used to go and work with
her literally straight after soccer
practice every weekend so I I think I
started around 8 D yeah eight so you've
been cooking for 20 years 20 I Wish I
Wish I Wish I Wish I Wish now um
breakfast what would you normally if
you're not fasting what would you have
for breakfast um honestly just eggs uh
usually eggs said sometimes actually I
do put a little smoked salmon on it cuz
I think it tastes good I'm kind of a
ketchup guy uh I don't know I sometimes
when I go to a steak restaurant and I
put ketchup on my steak they yell at me
so are you like one of those people or
do you know what yeah having five kids
they love ketchup they do is like
ketchup ketchup ketchup I like a spicy
ketchup okay ketchup good so he approves
that makes me very happy cuz what one
time we did a video where we ate like uh
multiple thousand uh steak or whatever
and uh I I asked for ketchup and the
chef literally almost kicked me out of
the restaurant he was just like what did
you just say I was like oh never mind oh
that does smell good you're going to
make me cry so we're halfway through
this now okay so the butter is melting
I've grated some beautiful truffles in
there like that okay and now we're just
going to fold that back in go on and off
the heat this is the secret so I've got
truffle a little bit wow of AG parmesan
I'm use that as a sort of salting aspect
so I don't actually season it with salt
use that cheese you can see this makes
me want to give up on YouTube and become
become a c this looks so fun now did you
ever think when you were starting out
with those videos with your mates
literally 10 years ago yeah who are over
there the goofy goobers you'd be into a
100 million subscrib subers uh well yeah
kind of I I knew when I was 13 that I
was going to do this till the day I died
just cuz I I loved it from the very
first video I made so I was just in my
head I was like well if I do this long
enough eventually I'll hit whatever goal
I want and so it's kind of always been
my mindset sure uh what I always say is
like the luckiest thing that can happen
to someone is like finding what you love
at a young age and I had that and so did
you absolutely and also it's not a job
right it's a passion exactly but I think
lockdown taught was a lot because
everyone went online and those videos
started repopulating and becoming
YouTube viewership went up like quite a
bit Yeah crazy it's crazy so we're oh my
go just come to the end they look so
mushy too they don't look like too hard
I like it and to stop them from
overcooking okay just going to grab a
touch of creme fresh in there oh my gosh
I don't even know what that is but nice
tart sour cream fresh yo screw it I
think we're I think we're breaking our
fast here boys and then just look and
then CH come come over here touch uh so
I think Gordon's going to make me I
think Gordon's going to make me shave my
head bro look look at that you're I'm
watching him cook it's been 14 days
since I ate food I think I'm going to
Cave so a little touch of it's l making
me cry I okay can you tell that I'm like
borderl crying just think I'm
sarry oh my gosh that was smell good but
strong I'm
very from there it's a little touch of
lightly cured Scottish salmon okay maybe
it's not that I'm hungry maybe it's just
being over here you just give me
that comes
on oh my gosh and then finally just a
little touch do you serve this at your
restaurant these are so special holy CRA
they're not on the menu okay cuz if this
was on the menu it would take us all day
getting these things done and then
finally a little touch I don't think put
anything else that looks just a touch
there and all right well and there we go
beautiful oh my gosh breakfast sandwich
man come in I hate least take a bite
you've been the first person in my
entire career that I've cooked something
from start to finish you've never eaten
please guess just I guess there all I'll
take one bite and I have to spit it out
technically CU of refeeding syndrome but
I still want to just taste it it's not
going to be hot so you're breaking the
fast I'm going to break the fast yes
enjoy this moment don't bring up that I
got to shave my head give me one minute
a piece before we shave my
head okay all right it's supposed to be
sloppy oh my Rich
delicious I love it I love it that is
bro I'm supposed to spit this out cuz
refeeding it's the wor thing I've ever
tasted in my life but you can't just
have an influx of carbs after not eating
14 days let me show you something let me
okay first off you cuz I have to
shave my head second I don't know if
you've seen this but we ate a $70,000
Pizza one time did you ever see that
video
$70,000 yes so where is it
um so we ate $100,000 ice cream we ate
world's largest slice of pizza where is
it $70,000 Golden Pizza I've ate
$110,000 steak everything this I don't
know how much this cost but this is
literally better than all that this is
the best thing I've ever had and I've
had food that literally cost over 100
Grand a meal that was crazy amazing
amazing try it Carl try that it did cost
your hair right where are the Clippers
okay well technically it did cost my
hair can I shave it
uh thank you that was great right feel
energized just having that in me bro
after 14 days I actually have a like a
boost of energy even though I didn't
even swallow it the spike has happened
here we go thanks so much for watching
scrambled and thanks to the amazing Mr
Beast don't forget to subscribe to our
YouTube channel to get more amazing
videos like this take
care